welcome to this video it's a 15-minute
game and this is an additional bonus for
the Christmas days so I'm going to do
three videos for Christmas Eve and the
two main Christmas days so um I wish all
of you a Merry Christmas with those
videos I didn't do any Christmas wishes
in the Bliss games because I recorded
them far beforehand and don't I didn't
really know when when video actually
will be the Christmas video alright so
this 15-minute game played a very early
crew g-form janet's probably not great
but i don't know how but like best
response to that well c5 cannot be wrong
really he's some playing like it
actually could be wrong still it's
strange okay let's see if I'm going to
play yeah well I get deform and this
cannot be bad come on playing Queen g4
not be five this cannot be great if he
plays 96 I'm taking it twin g7 look F
886 and then nice angsty form and I have
the far better development term there's
also the question to be no I just play
that and I just I was briefly thinking
about taking on default but this this
alone should be should be quite ok i get
i get to take on the form
and however let me briefly consider if
there is some some other way to play if
I go 94 yeah you can take you can play
Bishop d3 hmm
yeah that's actually quite okay from
white Bishop d3 cover c2 and I cannot go
see for attacking the bishop because the
night is hanging
yeah well it's not a terrible problem
but I expected I expected more somehow
okay and making also play mm-hmm can you
play Queen takes h7 covering see too
well Bishop d3 look son look lie looks
like the most natural move anyway what
what should I play after that it's
really a question he's he's intending to
play c3 kicking the night back hmm yeah
yeah Bishop b3 I don't really see what i
should do against that i mean i can can
play on him look like that's a queen of
six you know queen of six square I could
play
sort of winning a tempo on the Queen and
protecting the light so if he takes on
edge time now place your form but he's
not going to take on 87 hmm is there a
way to to have a good answer against c3
yeah one possible answer could be in
between 8-5 doing for the pin ok Knight
f6 you can play Bishop g5 this is
entirely entirely crazy it doesn't look
right up ok let's do that if you go see
three I can I can probably play C for
the other idea is c3 night be five and
then take on d6 with an ID I have the
general problem that Bishop h6 the Sun
in the position as well where you might
attack the the rock end I have no way to
retreat it somewhere this is also why I
want to attack be too so that he cannot
easily move the bishop
yeah the most natural movie has some c3
of course it's not playing it yeah I
have a simple solution now take e to
take t6 where I'm porn up at least for
the moment I mean age 7 s not exactly
strong okay take it and yeah okay let's
get rid of the d6 pawn if it takes now
on on h7 this is Bishop age 6 idea
11 ideas Queenie five so on Bishop h6 I
have Luke age eight
this could also be yellow it doesn't
matter i played something else entirely
and not a move I expected really castles
if i play Queen e5 now queen age 7 does
look a jade and a winning made on edge
too yeah okay so this basically
exchanges queens oops isn't this like a
Christmas present yeah there's no way to
attack my queen no counter-attack f for
the screen default check the Bishop f4
I'm taking the Queen there should be 595
and have a piece up yeah and got any
Queen move the screen age to mate check
you had resigns
yeah bit of a sudden end to this to this
earth resins game it was a really
unclear position here yeah maybe you
should just play Queen back I have the
spa and it's quite nice to have the the
extra pawn but it's not a clear-cut when
he's got to the ship's something
something like that for example is it
entirely clear yeah in fact he gets he
gets a corn back here just one possible
line some a bit tricky yeah I have a
hard time to believe that that this
should be great for white but maybe it
is a possible possible way to play the
computer says that this is very very
good for what yeah I didn't really
didn't really see it that way I thought
that sea fog the ship h7 I'd be five
would be interesting but the comp um
yeah it always has this at the end
the computer says why it is winning hmm
yeah it looks very shaky and I don't
have a good development yeah this was
probably very good for white then which
means i need to play something else I I
had seen this idea but then we'd be six
appeared to me more yeah this is
probably okay for a while for black at
least it shouldn't be a big big issue
here this pawn can be can be one
probably and this would mean black as an
additional bone but why there's a very
strong bishop am so that isn't isn't
clear at all this young this is more
interesting how to hard to save the
exchange yeah what's in trouble here but
a very tricky line here does this mean
that let's check this briefly this a
mistake no cannot cannot be really maybe
here maybe here I need to take on d4
that's possible yeah this is stronger of
course this is stronger because now this
is without any point just winning
everything so he needs to focus on the
d4 pawn and cannot win on g7
yeah that's better a very strange line
and it was successful for him opening
why say I really was in trouble alright
thanks for watching